[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain the third part of a drama
mini-series called clickbait
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
sarah's brother simon and his friend
daryl are hiding something about nick's
case from the police when detective
roshan informs paya about him being in
sacramento to meet simon piya drives
there as well on her way she is looking
at simon's socials and sees he has
posted a picture of him and daryl the
day nick was kidnapped she goes to the
motel roshan is staying in and meets him
paya points out the picture simon posted
and claims that it could be fake because
the rest of simon's feed is only
politics roshan says he notices that
himself but doesn't react much paia asks
him what they should do now and moves
forward towards roshan they make out but
roshan stops her midway saying that this
could lead to being taken off the case
meanwhile simon is packing his luggage
hurriedly to run away from the city as
he packs the box with sarah's belongings
catches his eye he brings it out and
reminisces about his sister the scene
changes to three months prior when simon
is devastated after sarah's death he has
seen the last text messages exchanged
between sarah and jeremy and blames the
man for killing his sister he reads his
sister's journal where she has written
everything that jeremy has ever told her
from the journal simon and daryl find
out that the couple planned to meet at
an oakland lynx game from this
information they figure out jeremy is
actually nick and are able to get his
address and personal information the
morning nick got abducted simon and
daryl waited for him on his daily route
to work a nervous simon sedated him
forcefully and took him inside the van
back in the present simon is about to
leave the city when he is approached by
roshan and a police officer they want
him to come to the police to get his
official statement simon obliges and
gets inside his own car while the
officers get in the police vehicle but
before they can leave simon gets out of
the car and runs away roshan follows him
behind and a chase ensues between the
two at the same time paya goes to
simon's apartment building and sees
daryl trying to run away he recognizes
her and asks her what she is doing there
piya sees a gun on the man and stays
quiet daryl tries to abduct her but she
manages to strike him with her keys and
escapes simon on the other hand is
eventually caught while being arrested
he thinks of the events that happened
after they abducted nick the scene cuts
to 11 days prior nick is kept in a van
with his hands tied after he regains
consciousness he asks the abductors why
he is there daryl angrily tells him
about sarah but nick claims he doesn't
know her when he asks what happened to
sarah an enraged simon hits him in the
face they make him write i abuse women
and at 5 million views i die on the
paper and videotape it simon uploads it
to the internet saying that nick's life
is now officially over daryl however is
still not satisfied he writes i killed a
woman on the third paper and makes nick
pose with it nick retaliates saying he
didn't kill anyone he asks simon how his
sister died and finds out that she
killed herself nick asks more questions
about her death angering simon even more
he punches neck repeatedly making him
sob in pain after a while the video
reaches three and a half million views
nick asks simon what makes him think
nick killed his sister simon pulls up
his dating profile on his laptop and
shows it to an utterly surprised nick
nick claims that it is not his profile
because he has a wife and two kids
simon in turn tells him about sophie
cheating on him which surprises nick
because he hadn't told this to anyone
yet when nick still denies knowing sarah
simon shows a picture of him and sarah
on a beach nick claims that it is
clearly photoshopped but the other two
don't believe him sometime later nick
tells simon that his father also killed
himself he reveals that he and paya had
found their father's body when they were
just kids since nick also has a sister
he knows what simon must have gone
through nick tries to reason with simon
saying that he knows how it feels to
lose a loved one he then asks simon to
show him that picture again simon brings
out the picture and sees the level of
the horizon doesn't match so the picture
is clearly edited right then daryl calls
simon outside saying that the video is
at 4 million now back in the present
simon sits in the interrogation room
with roshan the detective asks him about
his relationship with nick but simon
doesn't speak instead he asks to speak
to nick's sister roshan is surprised but
asks paya to come in anyway she sits in
front of simon who stays quiet for the
most part pair reminds him that although
he avenged his sister's death he will
never get to be with her or hug her
again she is gone and nothing will bring
her back at last she asks him what he
accomplished by killing her brother we
are then taken back to the time the
video had just hit 5 million views simon
and daryl are outside the van an excited
daryl hands simon a gun saying that it
is now show time daryl opens the van's
doors but is instantly attacked by nick
who has freed himself daryl asks simon
to shoot nick but he doesn't nick runs
away but is still followed by simon he
soon find nick and holds him at gunpoint
nick explains that whoever did this had
access to his family photos his life and
his marriage he knows who it is because
he had only told one person about his
wife's affair nick promises to find the
person who drove sarah to her death and
begs simon to leave him at last simon
lets him go revealing that he in fact
didn't kill nick simon apologizes to
paya and tells her that he let nick go
roshan however doesn't believe him in
the following scene we see nick's son
ethan texting someone named alison about
the murderer being found he thanks her
for being there for him all this time
the next day the brewer's sons returned
to school for the first time since next
disappearance it is easier for them
because sophie teaches at the same
school she asks the boys to stay out of
trouble and leaves kai's friends welcome
him back but ethan is confronted by a
bully the bully makes jokes about
sophie's relationship with curtis which
angers ethan but he doesn't react kai
who has been listening to the
conversation nearby loses his temper and
attacks the bully they get into a fight
which is stopped when ethan pulls kai
away the bully's nose is left bloodied
after later both ethan and kai are at
the principal's office with sophie ethan
texts his internet friend alison saying
he might be in trouble at night the
family is having dinner when ethan asks
paya what nick's murderers looked like
paya answers that they looked sad she
then reveals that simon said he let nick
go because he realized he had gotten the
wrong person andrea says the killer is
obviously lying but paya believes him
sophie takes her aside and asks her to
keep the conspiracy theory to herself
she doesn't want to give her kids false
hope that their dad might have been a
good person some time later ethan is in
his room texting allison again he tells
her about pius theory making alison
question more about the matter he then
watches a video of mandy the artist who
is one of the girls nick met online she
says that she had never met nick in real
life this shocks ethan because now the
only person alive who is claimed to meet
ethan is emma and if she is lying nick
might be innocent ethan texts alison
about this as well the following day
sophie leaves for work leaving the boys
behind ethan calls paya but she doesn't
pick up so he goes to her work to meet
her he then tells her that nick never
met mandy making her believe that nick
might be innocent paya calls emma to ask
her but she doesn't pick up the two then
go to the police station to inform
roshan about the matter meanwhile sophie
finds out from the principal that the
bully's parents are trying to press
charges against kai she requests that
she arrange a mediation so she can talk
to the parents directly the principal
agrees to do it but suggests to sophie
that she and her kids should leave the
school to avoid more chaos in the
meantime paya tells roshan that mandy
has never talked to nick but roshan
dismisses her because that doesn't prove
anything he says he will give emma a
call to confirm and continues to another
case while returning home pius sees
ethan texting someone constantly and
asks him who it is ethan reveals that it
is his internet friend who he likes paya
asks him to make sure he is not being
catfished when he returns sophie then
asks ethan to stay home and leaves with
kai to meet the bully's father ethan
goes through his and alison's messages
and notices a pattern of texts where she
urges him to tell her more about nick's
case he quickly asks her to meet him in
real life but she claims she cannot meet
him because she has an anxiety disorder
ethan realizes that he has been
catfished he throws his phone away in
frustration but receives another text
from alison she has sent him her
location so he quickly leaves to meet
her when he finally knocks on her door a
middle-aged man greets him ethan calls
him out for catfishing him but the man
turns out to be allison's father he then
meets alison who invites him in
meanwhile paya goes to vince again to
ask him to figure out who was pretending
to be nick in the dating profiles vince
in turn tells her about tara the girl
who dropped out of the volleyball team
after arguing with ben she might be able
to tell who was behind the fake profiles
in the meantime alison and ethan
instantly bond and start talking about
nick's case allison suggests ethan call
emma on his own because she might answer
his calls since he was supposed to be
her stepson the two get her social media
profile and video call her to their
surprise she picks up the call ethan
greets her and directly asks her if she
has met his dad at first emma says that
they were in love but then nervously
admits she never met him alison videos
the conversation after the call alison
tells him that if she gets the pictures
that fake nick sent to emma she can use
the metadata to find where they were
sent from ethan promises to ask emma for
the pictures and leaves paya on the
other hand goes to meet tara who tells
her that she and nick were fighting
because he didn't want her to leave the
volleyball team it turns out that nick's
co-worker matt and tara had an affair
when she ended the relationship matt
uploaded her nudes to the internet nick
was helping her through the situation
and not abusing her paia is beyond
surprised to hear this she realizes that
matt the one who made those fake dating
profiles and rushes to his work to
confirm she barges into his office and
asks another co-worker don to unlock
matt's computer which she reluctantly
does at first she finds tara's pictures
then she sees every picture used in
nick's dating profiles on matt's
computer she is now sure that matt is
the culprit paya takes pictures of the
computer's screen as evidence in the
meantime ethan sends the pictures to
allison for her to find out the address
kai barges into his room and sees him
closing the tabs abruptly he asks him
what is wrong but ethan dismisses it
sophie calls them down to have a chat
she tells them about wanting to transfer
to a different school for a fresh start
ethan takes this opportunity to show her
the video of emma admitting that she
never met nick hearing this kai sneaks
into ethan's room and goes through his
computer just then alison texts ethan
the hacker's address kai reads the
messages and figures out the address is
of the person who stole nick's identity
in the meantime paya calls roshan and
tells him about the pictures she found
on matt's computer roshan thinks she is
overreacting at first but then believes
her when paya gets to her apartment matt
is waiting for her outside asking her
why she broke into his office paya
accuses him of abusing tara but he
denies posting the pictures online he
gets aggressive but leaves when pai's
roommate arrives meanwhile sophie checks
up on her sons and finds kai missing we
see kai on his way to the address that
alison had sent ethan he wants to take
revenge on the person who faked being
his dad and even has a baseball bat with
him back home ethan checks the find my
fam app and sees kai has turned his
phone off sophie gets more worried by
the second and calls paya just then
ethan notices alison's last text and
figures out where kai must have gone the
scene changes to nick's very first day
at work matt takes him in and introduces
nick to the administration manager don
gleed back in the present kai finally
reaches the address and knocks on the
door
don opens the door and invites him in
she and her husband ed share a knowing
look while telling the boy to make
himself at home paya and sophie make
their way to the address in their own
cars
kai now sits with the old couple in
their dining room he asks them about the
catfish but don jokingly says they used
to have a goldfish kai feels
uncomfortable and says he wants to
return home instead of answering the boy
dawn asks kai if his mother knows where
he is kai lies and says he told everyone
before coming here ed offers to drive
him home and goes to his room to get the
car keys don follows him behind
nervously after that ed brings out a gun
blaming dawn for getting them into this
mess we are taken back to nick's first
day at work again don helps him set up
his computer and in the process gains
access to pictures from his phone and
his social media credentials when she
returns home that day we see her
lifestyle has been repetitive and boring
for the past several years at night she
is in front of her computer don
excitedly logs into a dating app as nick
one day at work don comes across nick
day drinking in his office she asks him
what is wrong and nick tells her about
sophie's affair he trusts her enough to
go into details which she later tells
the girls who she talks to as nick back
in the present sophie and paya get to
don's address and break inside the house
no one seems to be home but the two find
don and ed's picture realizing that she
was responsible for stealing nick's
identity meanwhile the couple nervously
drives kai away from his home don throws
kai's phone out when he tries to call
his mother kai begs the two to let him
go they stop the car at a ranch and put
the boy inside a trailer don is nervous
because of the gun ed possesses but ed
says that he is not going to jail at all
costs at the same time the police locate
their car in the ranch and drive towards
it dawn nervously tells ed she didn't
mean to hurt anyone ed in turn asks her
if she was in love with the women she
talked to as nick but dawn says she was
just lonely and wanted to live a few
moments as a young person like nick a
flashback shows don using a voice
changing app to talk to emma on the
phone she tells her how much she loves
her as nick
that night she mistakenly leaves her
laptop open and her messages are
revealed to ed he is furious with her
for stealing someone's identity just to
do something so childish dawn begs for
forgiveness but ed walks away right then
sarah sends her the texts threatening
her to commit suicide an enraged dawn
texts back that she doesn't care driving
sarah to actually kill herself when
simon let nick go that day he ran to
dawn's home directly because he knew she
was the only one who had access to his
photos and the one person who he told
about sophie's affair nick confronts don
for stealing his identity and asks her
to come with him to the police just then
ed from behind nick hits him on the head
with a hammer killing him instantly
back in the trailer kai manages to break
the glass window and escape the couple
runs after him after they leave the
police arrive at the trailer they spread
out looking for the couple and the kid
the police finally find dawn and arrest
her she claims that her husband has kai
and begs the police to let her see ed
because only she can stop him they soon
find ed holding kai at gunpoint don
apologizes and lovingly asks her husband
to let the child go he does as she says
and kai finally gets to sophie ed sobs
and points his gun at the police causing
them to shoot him dead don hugs her
husband's limp body on the ground but is
soon dragged away by the police roshan
finally drives the brewer family back
home then we see sophie put next picture
back up in the house again knowing that
her husband was the person she knew and
loved after all the scene cuts to nick's
funeral roshan tells paya that tara has
decided to press charges against matt
sophie stands at the entrance of the
funeral feeling overwhelmed but paya
manages to reassure her that they will
get through this by supporting each
other as a family the series ends as the
two walk into the funeral home together
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching